white house physicians monitor
everything
about a president including his
cognitive ability most presidents don't
talk about that of course
but this president was happy to in great
detail
when asked by our dr siegel watch
presidential health or health of a
candidate is going to be on the table of
course as
it always is and i've been someone
always asking for that i've seen a lot
about your health being in good health
what do you think should come out or or
be the attention regarding vice
president biden
well i think we have to be in good
health i'll tell you what this is a very
uh a very important job to put it mildly
there's nothing like it and i will also
say and i think i've had to work harder
than others because i've been attacked
from fronts that nobody ever got
attacked on you know with fake
investigations
fake russia russia russia ukraine
ukraine i mean
nobody's gone through and yet i've done
more than any president
in the first three years in history
there's no president that's done what
we've done with rebuilding the military
the judges
will be up to almost 300 judges
including two great supreme court judges
at the end of this term so it's really
something that's been great
but you need stamina you need physical
health and you need mental health
and because you have so much fake news
every once in a while you'd say
first they'd say he wants to take over
the world he's going to take over the
world he's a dictator the next day
they'll say
he's crazy the next day they'll say oh
he's incompetent the next day they'll
say something
so the last time i was at the hospital
probably a year ago a little less than a
year ago
i asked the doctor i said is there some
kind of a cognitive test
that i could take because i've been
hearing about it
because i want to shut these people up
they're they're fake news they make up
stories i mean like i'll do an interview
with you you i didn't say you can't ask
me about this you
i say ask me anything i did one with
chris wallace he was nice enough to say
he said i just want to tell the audience
there was no question
that's offbounds okay and he's a tough
cookie and it was a good interview i
liked it i enjoyed it
and it was good but i didn't say you can
only ask this you can only
we have to be sharp if you're in the
office of the presidency we have to be
sure
so they were saying all these different
things it was going all over whichever
stuck
none of it stuck fortunately but one of
the reasons it didn't is that i took a
test
i said to the doctor it was dr ronny
jackson i said is there some kind of a
test
an acuity test and he said there
actually is and he named it whatever it
might be
and it was 30 or 35 questions the first
questions are very easy
the last questions are much more
difficult
like a memory question it's like you'll
go person
woman man camera
tv so they say could you repeat that
so i said yeah so it's person woman
man camera tv okay that's very good
if you get it in order you get extra
points if you okay now he's asking you
other questions
other questions and then
10 minutes 15 20 minutes later they say
remember the first question not the
first but the 10th question
give us that again can you do that again
and you go person
woman man camera tv
if you get it in order you get extra
points
they said nobody gets it in order it's
actually not that easy but for me it was
easy
and that's not an easy question in other
words they ask it to you they give you
five names and you have to repeat them
and that's okay if you repeat them out
of order
it's okay but but you know it's not as
good
but then when you go back about 20 25
minutes later and they say go back to
that quote they don't tell you this
go back to that question and repeat them
can you do it and you go
person woman man
camera tv they say that's amazing
how did you do that i do it because i
have like
a good memory because i'm cognitively
there
now joe should take that test because
something's going on and and i say this
with respect i mean
it's gonna probably happen to all of us
right you know it's gonna happen
but we can't take a chance of it
happening when you're dealing with
russia when you and there's nobody been
tougher to russia than me nobody's been
tougher than
china than me i can tell you right now
they would love to see joe biden
instead of trump we've taken in billions
and billions tens of billions of dollars
from china
which they never gave us anything they
had the worst year before the play came
in they had the worst year
in their just about in their history 67
years
it was the worst year they had in 67
years before the plague
and we were doing great we had the best
economy but we have to have somebody
that's sharp if this person isn't sharp
because i can tell you president xi
is sharp president putin is sharp
erdogan is sharp you don't have any
non-sharp people that you're dealing
with
and we can't have somebody that's not a
hundred percent
so what i did is when the announce when
you know it's a public test and he said
you know if you take this test we may
have to reveal that i said it's all
right i've been
is it tough tell me about never heard of
it
and i got a perfect mark
and the doctors were they said very few
people
can do that very few people get that you
understand it's not that easy
there were other questions tougher than
what i just did but it's not that easy
but as soon as they announced my score
and that test
all the stuff went away about me is
incompetent remember they're talking
about 25th amendment and nonsense
and they said wow and even the enemies
they don't
say that anymore but they do say it
about
joe biden and honestly he should take
the test in a way as an obligation too
because
you have to be able to show this country
that the person that we're picking as
leader
is sharp because we're dealing with
people that want to do very bad things
to us if they had the chance
and you have to be sharper than them so
in a certain way joe biden has an
obligation to take a test
like that one or something else
there's more to dr siegel's interview
with the president you can catch it on
shannon bream show tonight
at 11 pm